l c legendary infamously intelligent MCM
MC you ruin
everything what do we do now welcome to
laughter Kenny wait no one here gets
offended too easily do no no one here
gets offended too easily that's
different why because there are real
problems in the
world why' you say just saying you can't
say just feeling a bit stuck don't get
stuck you're stuck like it's the whole
town with that phrase would just all
read it on the back of a box of sugar
cereal maybe I am stuck but the toughest
guy in letter Kenny rolls off the tongue
nicely doesn't it you are exactly where
you
belong anything can happen maybe it's
time for a change I just like don't
really know if I want to go back it's
about to get sankk in here
we would like to Cally invite you in a
spirit of family take about 20% offer
there bud Spirit of friendship more
Fellowship more radie no no thank
[Music]
you